thanks for being here with mcgriffin and
our new sponsor doordash for a limited
time you can get 25 off and zero
delivery fees on your first order of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter code griffin
okay here we go
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back
to your
absolutely
favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
again and guess who's back in the house
wiggy is here
wiggy's back in the house we're gonna
talk to wiggy we got some stuff going on
we got some stuff going on all right
we're gonna do some
some reviews uh
we're gonna recap uh just talk about
what's going on in the world just
another episode of riverboat griffin so
i'm really glad everybody's here once
again so thank you for being here and
you know all that good stuff um what
else make sure you catch me on
twitch eric griffin gaming i need that
and just guys welcome back
all right we did it back at it once
again
with griffin
uh
wiggs is back hello wigs thanks hello
back again back again um
in the house of griffin
it's just that the schedule's been
messed up but you know we're here it's
been busy everybody's been busy and
and all that stuff um let's see what's
going on with me
let me just get everybody caught up on
uh things that are happening so oh i
booked a commercial
so i did that i'm gonna do like a i
don't know if i can i guess i could talk
does it matter i don't play anyway i
booked a commercial so it is what it is
and then i had to go to chicago for an
event just one night and then i uh then
like the the call back for the
commercial was supposed to be at like 9
50 a.m and my flight was coming in at
like 9 20.
it was online anyway so it doesn't
matter it was like uh
they got this like you know like it's
sort of like zoom
you know what i mean and so
i uh
the flight was delayed an hour but the
commercial was still the callback was
still like gonna go till noon
so i get back and then like when i log
into the thing it's like all girls on
the screen
because they're doing that part of the
commercial
so i'm just sitting there
and then like the lady's like it's okay
eric we heard about your flight it's
fine and then like they called me you
know so then like the guy pulls me in
gives me the instructions after i waited
around for a while because they were
still doing these ladies
and then you know i go in the director's
like okay do this do that then next
thing you know
job booked
so hell yeah yeah hell yeah can you say
what what company i don't want to say
just in case i'm not supposed to say you
know but it's like it's like a i don't
know a one-year
buyout deal i mean the thing is is like
sag
they didn't take care of they did the
the internet the internet came about and
you know commercials and and all that
they just they weren't taking care of us
because they were putting stuff on the
internet so now the sag the union has
like you know all these different type
of distinctions and deals now that they
have to do with like oh you could play
this on the internet for a year you
could play it it's called new media and
all this stuff so
you know because back in the day see i
was in the commercial was called the
swear jar
it was this uh bud light commercial
yeah and um
really funny concept
the commercial actually won an emmy but
what happened was they never put it on
tv it was strictly on the internet they
were making people share it on like
myspace and facebook whatever the
app was at the time and it was getting
all this love but the actors we didn't
make any of the residuals we didn't make
any like the big money so it kind of
sucked i mean just recently and this was
like almost 15 years ago
and just recently bud light was doing
like an anniversary thing for
those old commercials and then my agent
hits me up like yo they uh they want to
use that commercial so i made actually
more money this time than i did when i
first made the commercial like that's
the crazy part about it so you know but
anyways
um that's when they after that they
started to like really fix the uh
commercial deal you know they made it so
people can actually
you know because because it is value
there's value putting something on the
internet you can't just be like oh we're
gonna put this on the internet and
nobody's going to uh
uh you know
it's not the same as say tv when it's
even sometimes even our stronger reach
than tv
so i did that
that worked out
um
what else has been going on in my weird
life uh new podcast alert
new podcast yeah so there is a i i do
have a new podcast coming out it's uh i
can't
i don't know if he wants us to talk
about it yeah yeah i don't know if he
wants to talk about because he's like
real particular about thing
but it's coming september 15th i can
tell you what it is it's called gen to
gen like generation to generation it's
kind of similar to like you know when
wigs is here but you know this is a
whole different you know this is anyway
so i got another podcast coming out so
check look out for that it's called
gender gen
um what else oh so let me talk about
this because this is important so last
week on the podcast i was talking about
how i feel
about
um
you know getting married and marriage
and a wedding and all this kind of stuff
so rachel listened to my podcast and she
was really she was upset you know she
didn't appreciate
my perspective you know because because
of her own perspective and you know
after letting her talk it out with me
and i i really i heard her you know i
heard what she was saying
and so like last week i was just saying
that it was like it's hard for me to get
excited about a wedding because of my
own baggage about my mom having dementia
and you know
she's really the main source
family for me and it just really makes
me sad when i think about how she's not
really right there but rachel's
perspective was she was like hey
this is supposed to be about us
celebrating our love
and she wants me to be excited about it
for that reason like that's a great
reason to be excited about it and it's
not like get over it
you know it's just this is just another
way to look at it
and be happy about it and you know what
she was like 100 correct
you know i'm valid my feelings are valid
how i feel about it is valid but i don't
have to let that be
the thing that i obsess over i don't
have to be the thing that that holds me
back
from enjoying something that is supposed
to be beautiful
you know and so
with that mindset
all i needed was that little that little
change in mindset and so now
i can like look forward to
this thing that we're going to do
and you know and i think it makes her
feel better knowing that you know i'm in
it like that even though she understands
you know but for her it's like this was
a dream you know it's like you know she
wanted she thought about her wedding her
whole life and you know she wants it to
be like
exciting and like you know
every all parties want to be there you
know what i mean so and i totally hear
her i totally get that perspective on it
i i was letting my own baggage about
my mom and you know because it's still
fresh and it's still so painful that i
you know i'm letting that dominate my
whole feelings and i really have to like
take a step back and be like you know
what there's other things to look at
there's other
there's other ways to approach it and
you know so we'll see i'll keep you guys
posted
you know so now rachel always says i
need to talk about my wedding on the
podcast so we can get some wedding
sponsors
you know he's like she's like let's get
like you know we need we need a dj
uh we're gonna need uh wiggy's gonna be
our videographer so we got that we need
you know maybe we need a dress person
who want who you know
jewelry uh you know i don't know like
what stylus we need a stylist we need
like maybe there's a venue out there
that you just opened up and you want to
like use our wedding is like the oh eric
griffin got married here
um i don't know whatever so we're
reaching out to you know i'm reaching
out to wedding people so hit me up about
that
yeah so
that's that you know so wigs i know you
got some stuff
that you you've been dealing with
yeah um
a couple of you had a couple of your
friends pass away a couple of deaths
yeah r.i.p to uh to that yeah all right
to them uh inju and uh kawaii rap
i'm sorry sorry about that
yeah you know it's okay unfortunately
i've dealt with this many times at this
point and
it's uh it's kind of crazy yeah i don't
know i'm uh
i don't know a little bit numb to death
at this point um well that's uh that's
not necessarily a great thing i mean i
know but
i know it's not a great thing but
you know it is what it is turn your mic
down a little bit i think your mic is
spiking a little bit there we go so you
don't make it too yeah hello hello yeah
i think that's better yeah there we go
on the fly we work on things but yeah
you know i'm not saying i get what
you're saying you know we deal with
death
but it's like and i know the manner of
which these deaths
is another thing that's troublesome yeah
that's that's the unfortunate part that
i've uh dealt with more than uh too much
too many times than i should should
anybody that should deal with but it
sucks and unfortunately it's part of
life but uh
hopefully
like hopefully it can
hopefully finally be a wake-up call even
though it probably won't you know it's
not you know yeah for the people that
don't know what we're talking about
we're talking about addiction yeah over
just talking about an overdose people
yeah i had uh so
what thursday wednesday um
i was told that a friend that i was
closer to when i first moved to la she
was a photographer um
that she had overdosed and her roommate
found her
so that is uh
so with that and we uh
you know
um she struggled a lot and
she was super talented super sweet kind
person but she really
struggled with uh addiction and yeah it
was tough but
we put together a really nice memorial
for her at echo park lake and
a lot of people came and i like printed
up uh prints of her photos gave them out
to everybody and photos of her so that
was cool
and nice that everybody came and showed
support was it was our family there did
our family show up no her family she's
from chicago and she her family
relationship is iffy so yeah that was
always uh
something um but her family did reach
out and i
i've been in contact with her cousin so
that's good and yeah hopefully i want to
like set up something where like
like like a store that would always be
open that would drop ship like her her
prints and photos as like posters or
whatever and the money could go to the
family or whatever they choose to do
with it but that week i thought that
would be cool to set up but then
day after the memorial i wake up to a
friend the friend i planned that
memorial with and she's like brace
yourself like
like wake up is your friend here like is
rosky here like wake him up like i'm
like like brace yourself and i'm like
okay chill out just like slow down like
what what happened and then she's like
oh like
my other friend uh
kauai died and then he's like yeah if he
uh his roommate found him overdosed and
i'm like jesus i'm like oh my god
couldn't i didn't even like know what to
i don't know it's just
the worst worst possible way to wake up
from the previous yeah yeah yeah i know
i and then imagine being the person that
you wake up and find your roommate yeah
that's like that that's a tough you know
it's like you know just to talk about
these kinds of things it's like you know
addiction is a tough thing man and
anybody listening right now if you're
battling with your demons um
you know people a lot of people have you
know issues
and they're overwhelmed and they
self-medicate and so i do recommend
therapy you know better help they're not
they're not a sponsor this week but you
know betterhelp.com griffin you know
what i mean help you reach out to any
place like that it's not to be from it
doesn't have to be my thing it's just
any kind of therapy that you think you
you know it'll it'll really get you on
the path or at least you can start to
recognize the things that's going on i
mean because that's what happens i mean
addiction is tough i mean addiction is
you know once somebody's addicted it
seems like they're always addicted and
they just they're always trying to
struggle to fight that addiction
yeah you know so it's like you know you
have people like your friends who are
like you know
they're not bad people you know what i
mean that's the thing too people they're
not people aren't bad people uh they
just going through some stuff and they
don't have the coping mechanisms to
uh get through some people do like for
me i use comedy uh for me i just i'm not
that kind of person that i'm gonna i
have different vices i have you know
what i mean i'll play video games too
you know are all like you know whatever
that my thing might be
um but some people don't have that and
you had your that's what's what the
thing is you have to help recognize in
yourself or even even in a friend is
that when they are struggling they have
nowhere to turn and oftentimes people
turn to
drugs and alcohol and then it becomes an
addiction
so it's tough i mean i'm personally
dealing with it i have somebody in my
life who's like a brother to me i always
call him my brother and he you know he's
in a great program right now actually so
knock on wood for him so shout out to
him that that that's working out but
you know i had to do like they have like
a sort of al-anon type program there so
he tells me he goes hey you know you
zoom in you you zoom
they sent me the link but i thought he
was going to be a part of it but it
wasn't him it was just for the family it
was just like me and like these other
people whose kids or loved ones are in
this program and at first i was like
what the hell but then you know when you
see what
other people are dealing with like one
family was like they hadn't seen their
daughter in four years another one was
like you know this has been going on i
mean it's just it
it was overwhelming but i saw man here
are some people who are dealing with the
same thing that i'm dealing with
at on different levels it's like you
know you go the grass is greener because
you're just like damn i'm glad it's not
that you know
but
um
you know what the sad part about
addiction is that now
like i'm going through this
you know like i i have to like it's you
know so then we then there's like a
family counseling appointment that i
went to
it was by zoom and you know so here we
are
it's me him the counselor and we're
talking about everything
and i'm thinking to myself a little
resentful i was like why am i in therapy
you know like how why am i in therapy
because he got an addiction but it's
that's what happens
you know so because it affects it
affects everyone in your life yeah close
friends family
obviously yourself but so so here i am
you know we're having it out and it was
like very like emotional and and then
the the guy the therapist was like look
i would i would actually like to talk to
each of you individually so i can get to
know you a little better so then i have
this individual therapy appointment that
i'm dealing with but
yeah so it was just like
it was crazy but yeah but for me
i love i'm very curious person so i love
going through a therapy process
to discover something that i didn't know
about myself or to figure out why i feel
the way i feel about certain things
because a licensed professional can
recognize patterns and this guy was all
over it man you know like i'm an only
child single parent i've never met my
dad before and up until this point in my
life i've never thought that not having
a dad has affected me it's never really
been like a thing that i harp on you
know but sometimes i look at other
families and i'll be like oh that looks
great i love that you know wow that must
have been great or you know i see
somebody be like like even your wigs i
saw you when you know how you how you
are with your family i think that's
great use your mom and your dad and
they're still together and so i see
things like that and i don't necessarily
get jealous or envious but i don't i
didn't think that it really affected me
but after talking to this therapist and
like expressing how i feel about certain
things he starts to let me know like
well you know that's a lot of that has
to do with abandonment and i'm like
abandonment
and then you just start to really think
about it and you just go oh [ __ ] maybe
this is
that maybe i haven't dealt with this my
whole life and this is the first time
that i'm like really
taking that into consideration so
again because of my family member's
addiction and things that he's dealing
with now i'm in therapy to help me deal
with stuff and the next thing you know
it's like i'm learning some things for
myself so
again shout out to therapy yeah therapy
is good
shout out to therapy it's like an and it
is hard
it is a hard thing to start
you have to really want to do it and you
have to be open you have to let yourself
be vulnerable if you can let yourself be
vulnerable you will you i
i
strongly believe you will get something
out of it but if you go into it with a
like uh
you know you know you're you because
look
especially the smarter you are the
harder it is because when you you know i
consider myself a pretty smart guy you
know i got a common sense approach to a
lot of things and so when you feel like
you have a handle on life
it's hard to think that maybe you don't
or maybe there's some things that you
don't understand or maybe there's some
things that like oh
you know
it's a little missing puzzle piece that
puts it all together you didn't realize
how small that puzzle piece was but it
actually blends together some things
bigger concepts and so when you're like
you know you're you have a common sense
approach you think i don't need therapy
so that's where i was for many years and
then it was like when i got into it i
was like oh wow it was like you learned
about boundaries you learned about uh
you know again abandonment you learn
about so many different things that are
like just really life-changing
uh approaches to
the things that are going on in your
life so
not to beat the drum but i do
therapy is
important yeah you know and it's like
somebody like you wigs you got like a
sort of like a calm
sort of like you know deadpan approach
to everything you know everything's like
yeah so i won the lottery
and uh
you know i was at an orgy with ten hot
chicks yeah
you don't ever you don't ever seem to
get excited about anything yeah why why
is that
uh
i don't know i do get excited sometimes
you just you just don't verbally express
it
yeah or
yeah i don't know just it takes a lot
for me to yeah for me to express it
actually yeah that's what i'm saying
yeah yeah but i bet that's very
frustrating to the women that you date
yeah probably
yeah
that never dave you i bet that's been an
argument do you love me you never show
it you never see it yeah more or less
yeah so that's always that conversation
it's not always are you like this calm
too when you make love to you like
no that's the only time i switch up i
guess this is good
that's the only time you switch it up
yeah
okay that's good to know that all you
ladies out there he will switch it up
for you
he will come he will come with the
emotional thunder when need be they're
like why why aren't you acting like that
all the time
yeah exactly
what you turn into a different person
what do you like i don't know yeah you
can ask them all right well give me some
references
anybody out there that has made
passionate love to wiki please send your
emails to eric at errorgriffin.com if
you have pictures video
good
screenshots of text we will take all of
that we'd love that one man
all right anyways
back to it um
but overall like i say
just uh keep that in mind everybody uh
if you need some therapy
you know if you don't think you need
therapy i'm telling you you might need
some therapies everybody could do you
might as well try yeah you might as well
it doesn't hurt to try exactly
what's up guys let's talk about doordash
um you know i love this service uh you
know i
rachel and i we don't always want to
cook and so when you want your food that
you just you go on doordash they have so
many different restaurants it's a good
customer service you know
it's easy to use
and they come right to your door and
that's what it's all about right so
getting what you want from the
restaurant that you want you don't have
to worry about you know right now we're
still in a pandemic so it's like
sometimes you just want that stuff from
that great restaurant and you just go
hey can you bring it to my door that's
what door dash is about and then what i
love about is when you're craving stuff
like ice cream or donuts or some bad
stuff that stuff's available on doordash
too like we order donuts all the time i
love that you know you didn't hear that
from me but that's that's what it
happens with over 300 000 partners you
can support your neighbor neighborhood
go to
of your choice you know because that's
the thing too
a lot of these restaurants
who need our support
this kind of thing doordash helps keep
those places alive and thriving and they
need that right now ordering is easy
and your items will be left safely
outside your door when you choose
contactless delivery the contact desk
delivery option so check that out now
guys for a limited time our listeners
can get 25 off and zero delivery fees on
their first order of 15 or more when you
download the door dash app and use enter
code griffin that's 25 off up to 10
value and zero delivery fees on your
first order when you download the
doordash app in the app store and enter
code griffin
don't forget that's code griffin
25 off your first order of doordash
subject to
subject to change terms apply
start eating good today
doordash
you know what turn your mic down a
little bit more i forgot to put a bit
yeah hello hello is that better yeah cuz
i forgot i put a setting on it i put a
setting on the thing that it's like a
different extra booming lab yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
the tacoma
this sunday sunday sunday sunday too
much too much um okay what else is up so
i've been doing king and a sting i did
like four episodes of that and that
that's been pretty fun and the king of
the things you've been great yeah
they're good good uh feedback from them
those guys so that's great that's been
fun you know i think theo
you know people keep asking why are you
shooting at dlc it's like believe me we
before we start filming we're always
like yeah you guys talked about yeah so
you should sit here bro you know but
he's like i get it you know theo is
going through his own thing too so i'm
just stepping in to help you know
because when he's got a town and all
that kind of stuff so i mean those
episodes have been great i might be i
don't know if i'm going back or not but
it's like you know i'm sure it'll be
better when i can i will and so
that that's been going on that's fun
um
steven is black but
yeah
i'm going to get steve to come on the
podcast just get steve and tell him to
bring the black button but he's been so
busy you know because now he's doing
that all the time yeah he's got his
scissors big dog now he's got his own
podcast so steve's like a mr busy guy
now i think he's making money he's going
to move so like steve steve's moving up
in the world upgrading one bedroom yeah
steve's upgrading yeah you really do
listen to the vodka
so let's see um all right so let me just
talk about some shows that i've been
watching
i want to talk about a couple of shows
i've been watching the first one is
uh you know okay so i used to have dc
universe it was a streaming service
so it was like the dc you know so dc
comics you could get comic books
and they had like exclusive uh so they
had doom patrol star girl
um and teen titans or the titans and the
titans if you know the dc universe
that's like robin um what's his name
jason
j not jason todd but dick grayson jason
sedakis no no no talk about the
characters
jason todd is the the new robin
you know and then dick grayson bisexual
robin um i'm not sure which one actually
i don't know if jason todd is the one
that ended up i'm not sure if it's jason
or look that up google that i'm not sure
which one it is
but in any way in the store in in in
that universe you know uh robin becomes
nightwing as he gets older you know and
he has his own way of doing things so he
has these titans
and um you know so i saw the first two
seasons on dc universe and the first
thing i liked about it is the fact that
it's rated r there's like cursing and
sex and violence i like that i'm an
adult i want adult stuff and i love that
you have this cartoon you have this
kidnap cartoon but you have a comic book
world and you put some more realism on
it and that's what i really like so the
first two seasons it was cool it was
good it's not the greatest acting in the
world if i'm being honest okay uh that's
money knock on it it's like you're not
watching the godfather okay it's like
it's some corny acting a lot of times
but you know what it's surrounded by the
dc world all right and it's completely
separate there's not like it like how in
the marvel where they had the mcu and
everything's connected this is its own
separate universe
and it is what it is and so i you know
the seasons i'm in mid-season right now
with it this is like a you know a new if
you saw season one and two
a lot of stuff happened
and now they're they're you know the the
titans are trying to like be the new
superheroes and they're based out of san
francisco in this story but something
happens in gotham and they need to go to
gotham to help batman
now my my biggest knock on titans and
you can watch it on hbo max and i
believe cw i think the cw has like a
a pg-13 version or pg you know they
probably take out all the cursing and
all that kind of stuff but you can watch
it on hbo max and it's like full on what
you want to see but the one knock i have
on this show and it is a huge knock on
the show in my opinion
is the dude playing batman i
do not believe he's batman
i i just i cannot
wrap my brain around this guy being
batman and i know in this universe this
batman is older he's like at the end of
his you know he's probably 50. you know
like this is that 52 55 year old batman
who's just kind of like hey i can't be
batman anymore but i'm doing the best i
can and you never see him in the batman
suit that's another thing because it
ain't about batman the story's really
about
the the titans but the dude playing
batman is just like i don't know if you
have it on the screen wigs but i just do
not believe he's batman like we've known
batman now for 40 50 years like you know
this guy
um
yeah well you probably it's like a white
guy you know
he looks old i can't see
it doesn't it doesn't show you
no no because look
we don't get the monitor turned around
just text me the uh
and i'll look at it on my phone but yeah
i'm sure you have the the guy uh yeah
i'm sure i think that's him yeah you
know what i mean let me let me just go
to my phone here uh batman
titans
batman yeah it was that guy
yeah yeah yeah he's the guy in season
three is finally addressing his batman
problem
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's the guy
he was in game of thrones i believe
yeah
it's the guy that was in game of thrones
uh
anyways i just do not believe him to to
be batman yeah he doesn't look like uh
you don't look like a batman like he
doesn't look like a tough like batman is
supposed to be chiseled because he's
been working out his whole life you know
he's you know what i mean yeah he's not
a christian bale type no he looks frail
and like he looks like alfred yeah yes
you know what exactly what i thought
it's almost like they they were gonna
cast out for and they were like oh man
we lost why don't we just have alfred be
batman that's what it feels like
but the dude's a great actor by the way
this isn't a knock on his acting it's
his physical prowess that i don't
believe
he's the dark knight okay so that's my
biggest problem with that show other
than also the cheesy acting
uh but the action's good and some of the
stuff's good and i do i do recommend it
if you're into comic book stuff so you
know this is a good you know and i'm
actually glad to see because they
canceled dc universe so like now it's
only comic books on dc universe they're
not and then hbo i believe hbo max kind
of like
brought dc into the fold so when you go
on um
hbo max you can see a lot of dc movies
and cartoons and stuff which i like and
that's what the dc universe was at first
yeah i think this is i think robin is
bisexual
um
oh i i they they don't address it
not in the show but that's just
something that the comic book characters
came out with you know whatever the
creators they say they made this as if
that's important okay i mean i don't
really care about that kind of stuff i
mean unless the only reason why i would
care about that unless you're like
specifically addressing it like if
you're doing a show and it's just
strictly about robin and you have to
show his love life and you want to say
okay robin's gay yeah or if you're going
to show if that's going to be like
pertinent to the story yeah in any sort
if but if it's not then then i don't
care yeah you know like you don't even
need to show that or sorry about it it's
not that
there's no there's no homophobia to it
it's just you're just kind of like
what's the point of having this you know
it's like it's like in this who's this
for you know
so if they are going to do that then
explore it then you know really explore
it you know like then then make that a
part of the story but you know because
sometimes you don't need to know that
information just like who cares because
now now you look back and you start to
change your view or it's like does it
you know i don't like when they do that
like they did that in harry potter when
they said they
they revealed jk rowling reveals later
that dumbledore is gay
you know it's like after the series is
over and all this you know by the way
dumbledore's okay that's so funny you
just kind of go wait what
like but i guess again it doesn't matter
but like it's like then
i don't do we need to know like is it
important like that's a real honest
question i'm asking is like do we need
to know the sexism
of the characters yeah obviously maybe
it sounds like she just created that
after the fact because
no i mean she could have been thinking
about it all along because it's not like
he was uh you know
again it just doesn't matter like you
you look back and go okay well that
makes sense because i know the series
i've read the books and i can go okay
and then apparently him and grindelwald
had a thing you know and that makes
sense too because they were so
passionate about each other that makes
sense so it's like if that's the thing
you go okay you know but it's like
that's dope you go you go you kind of
look and go
is this important so that's my question
now to you guys when you because i know
you're gonna troll the comments
is um yeah is that important to you is
it important because there might be a
feeling of like there are gay people out
there bisexual people there are these
type of people who are thinking you know
i'd like some representation you know i
want yeah yeah robin's one of us you
know and it's like okay cool and do you
want that to be explored or there's
other side of it who's like like it's
like i don't want to know about my i
don't want to know about these
characters i don't want to know that
they go to the bathroom i don't want to
know that they have
issues i don't want to know that they
have sex i don't want to know that they
what their sex is yeah but you know what
their sexual orientation is you know so
let me know what you think about that
in the comments but overall though
thumbs up for titans on hbo max watch
all three seasons season three is going
on right now and it's uh i'm not sure
where
biggest season
episode six or seven is out right now
i'm not sure
i don't know when that comes out hello
it's really good so check that out
um the other show i wanted to talk about
finally because i said i was going to do
it last week but i was doing a live
episode and i just forgot to talk about
it and wigs actually mentioned this show
to me and so i actually watched it
everybody i think everybody like it it
went kind of viral right it's kind of a
pop and show yeah it is everybody's
hyped on it yeah so that show is white
it's pretty lotus
and white lotus is
fantastic listen to me it's fantastic
yeah that was pretty good my buddy of
mine who was in i'm dying up here with
me yeah jake lacy
is on the show
and he is i i hit him up to tell him and
i'm going to get him on the podcast yeah
and stifler's mom yeah can i talk about
a [ __ ]
that's a good show all in the comments
right now people are like wigs needs to
slow shut the [ __ ] up wigs
that's what they're going to be saying
right now
yeah you're gonna be like wiggy came
back shut now shut the [ __ ] up
welcome back now quiet yeah um okay so
my buddy jake lacy
i told him i hate your character and
that is just a testament to how great
he's doing as an actor like it's such a
like
he plays this annoying spoiled rich guy
who is just complaining about his room
the whole time so white lotus was made
by i believe the guy's name is mike
white he
directed wrote and was the star in one
of my favorite movies of all time school
of rock yeah he played schneebly yeah
ned schneebly
so he played he wrote this show and and
it's so good it's about uh these like
privileged people that go to this like
hawaiian resort
and and all the things that happen and
all the issues that they deal with and
the people that work at the resort yeah
they deal with race they deal with
family they deal with uh economic you
know differences and
uh money and it's it's
it's just it's a great show about
interpersonal skills and about people
how they connect and how they don't
connect and people that make tough
choices in their life and and so he's
great and the main the chick that plays
his wife uh what's her name i always get
her name wrong um
let me just look up white lotus cast so
i can see it on my phone here white
lotus cast
uh oh yeah alexandra d'addario
she was like a teeny bopper
she was like a teeny bopper actress and
all those type of movies she's got like
amazing eyes like that's her thing she's
beautiful and her just her eyes are just
captivating you know what i mean so
she's great now she's this phenomenal
actress like she's doing a great job in
the show yeah she's great and then like
he said stifler's mom jennifer coolidge
like she's gonna get it she's gonna get
nominated for something i think i think
jake's gonna get a nomination i think
i think everybody in this show like you
said you hate his character like he's
really so annoying yeah and
uh what's his mom's name who's that
actress she's big too all right oh molly
yeah exactly yeah so like it's just you
know so again it's a show about and it's
only like six episodes too you know yeah
it's you know when the show opens up um
you know the show opens up you know
where the
like actually the show opens up at the
end that's right something i really
enjoy too you know there's like a murder
there's a murderer committed wigs let me
finish
i have to scold him now it opens
okay
the show opens there's a murder that
happened during the duration of these
six episodes and and so you're gonna
find out how it happened
but they opened up at the beginning and
then it says three weeks earlier i mean
a week earlier or whatever it is and
then you know that jake jake's character
he's on a honeymoon with his wife and
then like this other character
she's like you know got the ashes of her
mom and then there's this family
uh you know this family where the mom is
the best you know sort of the
overbearing mom and the dad's kind of
weak and then he's got these two kids
and then the friend is there and then
there's like all these then the crazy
guy that runs the hotel he's insane he's
got his own issues it's just it's just
i'm telling you right now now i told
bobby lee about this i said to bobby i
was like dude you gotta watch white
lotus and he's always like i don't trust
you rick and we decided but i saw him
the other day and he was like
he loves it so
i do highly recommend white lotus and i
i wasn't going to watch it you actually
don't want to tell me about white lotus
so i was like i told you white lotus is
uh pretty good actually everybody on
this show is great man fred
the kid the kid yeah the the one that
plays the the kid
with that at first he's always on his
cell phone and then then he wants to be
like a yeah a rowing guy and the the guy
that plays um
oh my god the the resort manager
yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh good murray barlett he was really
great
so anyways that's not super you know
big toe up little and my thumbs up
big toes up four up
four four ups for white lotus
five toes you can see how excited he is
so that's what he won't even shut the
[ __ ] up so
did you uh speaking of uh your boy bob
did you watch um
reservation dogs
no that's pretty good
was he in that yeah he plays a doctor
reservation dogs yeah it's about uh
native americans
um
oh i saw the poster for the reservation
like these kids that yeah it was it was
good oh you oh okay you i didn't know
you took this much time to watch
television shows because you're always
listening to podcasts
it's sometimes i have both going at the
same time but i don't i don't like
probably pay attention enough as i
should but white lotus was good enough i
paid attention oh but i watch stuff a
lot i'm just like it's just like on in
the background while i'm editing or
something uh okay so you don't really
watch so
yeah something's always on though
so i'm all i just started a new show
right now and i think it's
i think it's on the cw
but i'm watching it on
um hbo max and it's called kung fu
weird name for what the show's about
so kung fu
is about this girl
who her overbearing family drives her
way and she she her mom sends her to
china and she thinks she's going on a
retreat but it turns out she sent her on
a dating thing to find a a chinese
businessman to be her husband
she runs away to a monastery
and the monastery it's like where they
train to kung fu and she like is
learning the arts of kung fu for three
years and then her
shifu which is her master
uh
gets murdered and uh in a mystic store a
sword is stolen and now she's on a quest
because when her when her the master was
dying she was like get the sword back
and so now she's on this quest to get
the sword but the action is great so the
lady the girl playing the lead she
really i believe her like the the way
it's shot and the way the the the the
what do you call the koi wait defining
is choreographed it's really good and
she really comes off as a badass and
it's like again it's like mostly
i believe it yeah it's a mostly asian
cast
um
and uh and they do this thing in the
show too that's great so they're always
talking in chinese right i believe it's
chinese and then they're like they start
talking like in the beginning of a scene
they'll be talking in chinese and then
like you know so uh a one a third 25
into the scene they're talking chinese
and then all of a sudden they just start
talking english so
you know
they're still talking chinese
but they're speaking english for us
you know what i'm saying it's like a
little trick that they do
um
but it's pretty good i mean it's cheesy
i mean it's you know it's pg 13 you know
it's just a cheesy corny story but i
love kung fu
so like if you add zombies or kung fu to
anything i'm on board 100
so this is a you know and i like when
it's like a female lead is like the
heroine and you know that's always like
an interesting thing and it's very woke
you know like her brother's a doctor
who's gay and he's dating a black guy
you know so it's like you know so you
got an asian guy and a black guy and
they're gay and it's like that kind of
thing you know uh
so it's it's uh you know and her
ex-boyfriend is wide and now she's like
gonna get with this asian guy who also
is kung fu and but it turns out he has
some mysterious past and it's like it's
that kind of thing so each episode is
kind of episodic because like there's
something that goes on in every episode
that she feels like she needs to go
rescue something and then the through
line b story is her trying to like get
this sword back but there's always
something like one episode there was
like a factory where you know the they
were being mistreated so she stepped in
another one where like a girl was
feeling a girl was being abused by her
stepfather so she goes and beats him up
you know what i mean it's like that kind
of stuff going on in the show so if you
just want to watch something a little
guilty pleasure i i would i would
recommend i'll throw that on while i'm
editing it yeah that's it would be one
of those you know yeah there's a lot of
the you know yes for sure um
speaking of uh choreographed fights
though i i actually went to a party
um
my friend of course you did i went to i
went to uh
ethan from shameless birthday party
um because my friend is really good
friends with him and the kids from cobra
kai were there and i started talking to
him and i didn't know even who they i've
watched the whole show but that's
cobra kai yeah i watched the whole thing
you watch it no i've never seen it even
though my buddy two of my buddies are on
that [ __ ] yeah it's cool i mean it's
it's not like it's the same thing like
the acting's like you know it's all
right but it's it's interesting and it's
cool and the the fighting is the fight
scenes are
all right like you said the choreograph
the choreography is
choreographed choreography yeah
choreography is good it's pretty good
yeah but but what's funny is that i was
talking to the main girl like peyton
list i was talking to her for like 20
minutes
and i was like oh so what are you acting
and she's like oh i'm actually on cobra
kai and i'm like oh that's why you look
familiar but
she was like
i was asking her about the the fighting
stuff and she's like yeah we actually do
all of our own stunts and we get up
every day at six am to do karate
training did you uh so they actually did
you get her number no she's she's dating
uh the kid with the mohawk who's in uh
but jacob did you get her number
no i actually i i got i i exchanged
instagrams with the with her boyfriend
though um because he wants to make uh
okay because that that wasn't going to
where i thought it was going to go no
she's a cool girl but she i mean she's
dating
that guy and he was right there and they
were all talking to me and oh they're on
the show and her brother her two
brothers were also there talking to me
but we're they want they want to do a
magic the gathering youtube channel
they want me to
they want you to do what
like film and edit it i guess i don't
know look at you like you see there you
go you're you're the one yeah i don't
know i don't know how serious they are
about it you're that you're that guy
they're down i'm down yeah
all right
how much time we've been going uh 42
minutes uh you know what we're uh we're
winding right on track yeah we're right
on track uh you know um i don't know
what else is uh i uh i went surfing oh
okay but for the first time he's still
talking to everybody
you asked what i had queued up
now they're all cute and all right so
you went surfing yeah i went surfing for
the first time and it was kind of
partially in part by
okay well i thought you were gonna be
able to see these things but
um it's partially inspired by this uh
this docu-series hundred-foot wave
yeah what's that about you you kept
talking about that what's the
hundred-foot wave about it i got the
trailer plan but it's um
it's basically about a hundred foot wave
it's about uh
this guy garrett mcnamara and he's like
he's like a super legendary surfer i
think i had heard his name even before
um
before i had seen this just because he's
like a
crazy surfer so he searched like giant
waves and it's basically
he basically documented his search for a
hundred foot wave like oh i think i saw
this on and is it what's it on is it on
netflix it's on hbo yeah oh yeah yes
it's on hbo yeah so you i'm sure you've
seen a trailer for yeah
i mean that [ __ ] is
insane he he literally
the in in portugal in this one
town called nazareth there's
that's where the biggest waves basically
in the whole world the biggest surfable
waves exist and they only exist for like
a cert a season
all the major surfaces all these surfers
go there so this guy garrett like re
like uproots his entire life and lives
here for like a year and then he
essentially just lives there forever i
think i think he maybe even still lives
there now but
he it like he's just on the hunt for
this 100 foot wave and one day they're
like there here it is it's coming like
it's and he surfs this giant wave and it
looks like it's 100 feet but technically
it's only 78 feet uh but the concept is
the concept is the biggest wave in the
world so he set the record with that
with the 78 foot and they do that on the
show that you see it yeah it's basically
his whole journey of figuring finding
out nazareth and finding
the town and becoming cool with the
locals and basically he basically turns
this town into a surf town nobody had
ever i guess nobody had ever surfed
there before in the world but someone
went there and they were like they have
giant waves that's where the wave is
that's where the hundred foot wave is
and so he's like i gotta go and he goes
there and he
learns the seasons and learns the weight
i mean it's all this research i mean he
has a huge team he has like
three jet ski guys go out there like
and he has to like test these guys to
make sure he has the right people for
the jet ski to come save him i mean
it's intense but yeah if it's that big
of a wave i mean the undercurrent is
yeah no it's it's insane and there's
like one i don't know how many people
die
every year
they're surfing in nazareth yeah there's
got to be statistics about it i mean
because that's the thing about surfers
they're always willing to die
yeah i mean that is that's another
that's the whole thing that's another uh
that's another aspect of it yeah that's
another thing about him and how he has
to come to terms with reality that like
because he has a family and then it's
like oh he's gotta give up surfing and
then there's a woman who almost beat his
record she got she surfed a 68 foot wave
so she has like the height the biggest
women's surf which is right it's like
that show that it was like that
documentary about the guy that the the
mountain climber yeah exactly free fall
exactly is that what the name of it um
i think it was free fall or something
but he was that yeah i watched that i
mean that's
amazing
it's the same type of right it's the
same type of thing all right well
there's another but it makes you want to
surf another recommendation so i went
surfing another recommendation by wigs
to watch hundred foot wave and i believe
that's on hbo
yeah hbo so we'll check that out and it
says what happened it says that two
people um did die surfing nazareth yeah
see
all right so check out white lotus on
hbo check out 100 foot wave on hbo
actually check out
titans on hbo also big age all those are
on there and yeah and even kung fu is on
hbo so this is like all hbo recommend
recommendations i need to sponsor i know
they need to like sponsor me for talking
about them well you know what it's a
short and sweet one this week they don't
always got to be an hour um or longer i
got some get some more guests lined up
make sure you check out the paulie short
episode i did that live not live but i
did i recorded that in vegas at his
house
and that's still up that's an
interesting one and dean del rey that
was a good one too uh make sure dean's
such an interesting fascinating guy and
i'm still got my solo episodes uh i'm
gonna be doing but again i got my buddy
ian edwards coming soon i got uh steve's
gonna come back um you know then i'm
trying to get bobby and all these kinds
of people but you know for the most part
you know i want to get my buddy jake
lacy from white lotus to come on and
talk about it because he's also the
thing about him that
what's very interesting i know what i
know about him is like he's really
pretentious in a good way about acting
and art like he very much
cares about the art form and everything
he does is deliberate so the things he's
doing as this character it is all
constructed from him being a fantastic
actor so i really want to get him on and
talk to him about
all of that so
yeah look out for that man and thanks
for being wigg's back so thanks wigs for
being here this week thanks for having
me r.i.p to your friends and remember
like i say everybody out there if you're
struggling and you need some help get
some help man i highly recommend it you
it will help you
i believe it will help you organize your
thought if you go into it with the idea
that you want help that you need help
that you're going to get help
it's going to help you um so you just
find some some vulnerability in an open
mind and go check that out but again
guys check me out every day on twitch
eric griffin gaming
um shout out to our sponsor doordash
this week uh um
you know
look for the code griffin and yeah you
know uh we're here i'm here every week
so and make sure remember september 15th
to look out for my new podcast it's
called jen to jen
uh check that out and that that's with
me that doesn't matter to say it's just
with me and matthew espinoza uh since
young kid he's like 24
big social media guys you know and um
i've known him for like seven eight
years now
um and so you know he he approached me
about it hey he went through this
podcast and i was like okay so here we
are so i got another podcast coming and
i know you'll see me on king of the
sting again
and you know i'm doing what i do so i
appreciate everybody out there for
watching and i will see you next week
you